we're here at the California heritage
market in Los Angeles it's the very
first ever California farmers market
where people could meet the growers of
their medicine here in Los Angeles pot
is going artisanal thousands came to the
city's first-ever marijuana farmers
market over the fourth of July weekend
to purchase Bud direct from growers open
only to medicinal card holders the
farmers market promised patients access
to dozens of pot vendors without having
to go through an expensive middleman
it's also bringing more access to people
in a city that has cracked down on
medical pot shops in the last year the
market was born from the efforts of
Paisley Bradbury who serves as the
executive director of the west post
collective so the idea came from this
because we don't have a lot of
dispensaries in Los Angeles and as you
see that kind of limits the amount of
you know growers that people have access
to especially patients here and as you
can see there's a lot of people here and
I mean it's just amazing I think people
are really excited we have a line like
down the street and around the corner
and I mean that speaks more than
anything else
the reason this is important is because
Los Angeles has been under a tremendous
amount of regulation issues and so forth
and so on so together with west coast
collective which is a property compliant
dispensary we open this up to all of our
patient growers a lot of them are
veterans who grow extra medicine for our
patients and other members so this way
we can give them a better price with a
higher quality medicine today we have 30
vendors here and the amount of products
that are available are like everything
from edibles to concentrates - we have a
marijuana lubricant down there our
product is actually a cannabis infused
lubricant designed for women a lot of
older women have no options as far as
sexual enhancements so we really want to
get the word out there on this and even
more so it's all-natural though the
farmers market is a great opportunity
for businesses like Floria to get more
exposure its legality has been called
into question under proposition D a law
passed by la voters in 2013 which
restricts the number of marijuana
businesses that can operate within the
city California has also failed to
approve any measures that would legalize
cannabis
in the state bradbury maintains that the
collective is fully legal under the law
and is necessary for local patients to
gain access to medicine that they need
and so far the Los Angeles City Attorney
has left the market alone so what does
the popularity of this event say about
the climate of legalization in
California the interesting thing about
what's happening with the current
climate and the marijuana communities we
have two states that have full
recreational legalization that's
Washington and Colorado here in
California even though we were first to
legalize medical marijuana we're still
in a state of flux so there's a lot of
confusion about what is legal and what
isn't legal I do get a lot of calls
about the legality of this so what's
interesting to me is that this is
exactly the way that the law is written
we're supposed to be doing this patients
are supposed to be getting their
medicine directly from the growers
within the collective and that's exactly
what's happening here